so over the last couple of weeks you may
have heard some pretty surprising things
about cs go pro boomich he's been
accused of domestic abuse use of illegal
drugs and cheating on his partner now
boomish is suing his ex-wife for a libel
saying there's a lot of false
information out there but he also says
that he's being blackmailed so let's try
to sort this whole thing out
so this whole story starts way back at
the stockholm major last year where
na'vi's igl boomich celebrated his first
ever major win by proposing to his then
girlfriend angelica lee queen mikhailova
my girlfriend right now in moscow she is
watching this and i wanna ask one
question will you marry me
oh my
well that is a stage to do it on
bumich and mikhailova got married a few
months later in january according to her
instagram posts in late april mikhailova
announced that she and boomish were
getting a divorce but posted that they
were back together just a few months
later then in may navi announced that
bumit would be benched after the then
upcoming antwerp major due to quote high
reputational risks for the club at the
time this was rumored to be related to
statements made by na'vi ceo in an
interview with the washington post
mikhail klementov navi ceo yevgen harris
pelton zolotorov stated that the org was
not going to work with people who live
in russia and pay taxes to the russian
government and that the org was ready to
relocate their players who don't support
the russian invasion of ukraine notably
navi is a ukrainian org and most of its
staff is ukrainian too in the wapo
interview zolotorov said that he isn't
even sure if his house exists anymore or
if it was destroyed by russian forces so
it's not too hard to understand why
na'vi wouldn't want their players paying
taxes to the russian government now that
said zolotorov said at the time that he
hoped navi's russian cs go players would
relocate and that most russian gamers do
not support the war navi's cs go team
features three russian players
electronic perfecto and of course
boomish however boomich was the only one
of those players who was benched after
the antwerp major electronic even took
over as igl after he left though it's
unclear whether or not any of navi's
players have relocated then on june 8
mikalova made multiple posts to her
telegram in which she accused boomich of
domestic abuse according to a
translation done by a russian-speaking
member of our staff mikhailova wrote on
her telegram that boomich threatened her
and broke her tooth that he is a quote
messed-up mephedrone addict that he
cheated on her with a friend and that
the two are getting a divorce she wrote
quote i'm not as eloquent as boomic but
the truth is on my side he's been a drug
addict for a long time not me he gave me
panic attacks and ruined my mental state
with his friends he ruined our little
family he knocked my tooth out he ruined
my health he betrayed me multiple times
in every sense imaginable he stabbed me
in the back and i have to be quiet about
this he's weak not me the whole truth is
here no one knows him better than i do
she also released a short video of
someone she alleges is boomish snorting
an unidentified white powder that she
alleges is mephedrone she also allegedly
released a nude picture of boomich i can
say that we have seen the video in
question though we can't confirm whether
or not the person in the video is
booming and whether or not the substance
in the video is known as a drug and that
we have heard a lot of reporting about
the nude photo but can't confirm its
existence because we have not seen it
ourselves boomic then released a
statement on the 8th writing today i got
divorced from my wife and was
blackmailed with various photos videos
and also a huge amount of fake
information soon i will be filing libel
suits many thanks to everyone for the
support and understanding at a difficult
time for me a few days later on june
12th boomich posted a picture of him
getting the result of a drug test that
said he did not have any mephedrone in
his system when the test was taken there
were plenty of people calling for being
level-headed as there's little way to
know exactly what happened between bumic
and mikhailova at the moment while some
of boomwich's teammates took to
commenting about how they saw this
coming
[Music]
foreign
what bit is talking about in that second
clip are photos that allegedly show
mikhailova supporting russia with
regards to the invasion of ukraine on
april 6 mikhailova reportedly posted a
photo of herself with the russian flag
drawn on her cheek and while that photo
has been circulated in the media the
score esports couldn't find it on her
telegram or her instagram bit also notes
pictures of mikulovo with tanks which we
also could not find while researching
this story it's unclear if these alleged
photos were part of why boomers was
benched mikadova's mother doubled down
on her daughter's allegations that
boomich is a heavy mephedrone user
alleging that he went on week-long
binges while bumich's mother responded
by insinuating that mikhailova was only
with bumich for his money it is
currently unclear whether or not
mikhailova's allegations had anything to
do with boomish getting benched all
na'vi cited in their statement were
reputational issues and while this would
certainly qualify as a reputational
issue for the club it's impossible to
say until someone from na'vi comments on
the situation which means that this
whole thing is still pretty murky in his
original tweet boomich said that there
was both a lot of fake information and
blackmail out there implying that he
believes that at least some of these
allegations are true though to be clear
i could not tell you what boomich is
thinking right now it's possible that
there will be more allegations maybe
even from both sides as we get closer to
a possible libel trial meanwhile
boomij's career is probably on pause
while this all gets resolved because the
allegations here are quite serious
domestic abuse is a lot bigger than drug
use or cheating personally i don't think
any of us should care what bumich does
in his free time as long as he's not
harming anyone but if it does come out
that he did hit his ex-wife that is a
really big deal and we should take those
allegations seriously for now in the
meantime no one needs to jump to
conclusions this is a complicated story
and i'm sure it'll unfold even more over
the coming weeks
you